one of the most dynamic quarterbacks to
ever lace them up he's working with Fox
Sports right now but tonight he'll be a
correspondent on NFL the grind which is
the show that I host on epics he spent
some time with Philip Rivers in Keenan
Allen in the Los Angeles chargers last
week he's Michael Vick how are you
Michael
I'm doing good I'm doing I'm doing just
fine well what did you find in in
Phillip Rivers towards the end of his I
guess career or in the back nine that
he's playing there in Los Angeles
I found passion in this back nine I mean
his willingness to continue to compete
at a high level it's probably hard and
it was when he was younger and you know
you mentioned let me think about how
long he's gonna play or how long he's
going to continue to do it he just
lights up man and it tells me there's
sort of little rivers will be playing
for another four to five years because
he's having that much fun I think what
you get and you know this phase in your
career and I witnessed it when I was 30
34 35 I just love teaching young guys
you know how to play the game and I
think he's enjoying having young guys
command and helping them understand the
game of football and what it's all about
how to be the best at it so his passion
is what stanza y mean and you've been
there and you've done that you've been
on on teams that have superbowl
aspirations and folks might not know but
you can tell me what's the name of the
quarterback who came up with the first
road win for a playoff team in the
history of Lambeau Field Michael what's
the name of that cool that would be me
so you've been you've been there you've
done that and also you've been on some
teams that have fallen short did was
there any indication of the type of
performance the Chargers would would
would actually forward on Sunday night
football against the Steelers team start
in a third-string quarterback Michael no
it was no indication at all and even
been in the locker room with Claire they
were very vibrant seemed like they was
having a good time in there and feeling
good about the week they're coming off a
tough loss and wonder no get back for
not winning you know avenge the loss
things like that was the common goal for
everyone and just speaking to some of
the guys and I just would have never
seen that coming but it is
anything happen in the game of football
any given Sunday so much true to it how
does that happen is there a way that you
could just from your wisdom and your
experience just how you can put it
together we're all wondering what type
of team are the Chargers can the
Steelers actually replicate that with
Mason Rudolph should he come back after
thereby is there an answer to all that
Michael is it an answer to the charges
not going in and looking you know sort
of flat yes I think you know notes NFL
team comes into the stadium unprepared
what I think you can do is coming to the
stadium an underestimate an opponent and
when you got a guy you know and Hodge
the starting foot for the steel as a
third string quarterback you know you
kind of think that he's gonna make
mistakes and things are gonna happen in
your favor and it won't be detrimental
to your side and before you know it this
guy's prepared he's hungry you don't
know what type of play he is he comes
out and surprise you so I think that's
what happened to the charges and you
know for Pittsburgh for them to find a
guy who came in and played the way he
did under those circumstances on the
road you know sometimes you gotta just
continue to roll with the high hand that
Mason Rudolph he'll that's what the game
is all about michael vick joining me
here on the Rich Eisen show again you
can watch his work hanging with the
Chargers and Phillip Rivers on NFL the
grind tonight on FX at 9:00 eastern time
here in your name a lot Michael when
Lamar Jackson goes out and does what
he's been doing of late do you speak to
the kid at all yeah well we talk
occasionally uh you know I did a
sit-down interview what lashes they're
you know I was a workaholic he just
working on this craft every time you
know I seen something going on with them
or any time he texts I'll call it was
you know all this him just granting it
out putting in the work in his is
evident that you know the evolution of
him at the position I was starting to
take shape and form he's really hard to
deal with the system is built around his
game and what he could do and I think a
lot of these young quarterbacks are so
familiar with the
reassess systems that the startup
perfected in the NFL and it's a great
thing to see Lamar playing at a high
level is it true did I see a quote that
you think that he might be better than
you
Michael was that an accurate quote well
I said that three years ago when he was
in college and he dismantled Florida
State in front of the entire world and
you know a long thing I could do was
recollect back to the times that I
played but Virginia Tech and how you
know Florida State just gave us problems
and we we had him on the ropes but it
was a tough game and I had to do more
than enough to put us in a position in
southern when they gave us the see him
go out there just toy around with those
guys you know I think you know the next
generation should always be better and
you know it was you know almost for
certain for me to watch another guy come
after me see him do it a little bit
better and make it look a little bit
easier and I'm like you know this guy is
you know he's better than me he's better
than what I was and I said it in true
and true meaning and I meant it and I
meant for him to hurt and to motivate
him and I think he's he's taking that
around with it so what do you see when
he struggles Michael do you see
something that you went through in the
first couple years when you came out of
Virginia Tech what do you see on those
days when he's not like um you know I
think he's had some struggles early I
think one one of the struggles and I
think when it becomes the similarity to
me when I look at it is that some games
they go in and the playbook might just
not might not open up you know it might
not open up enough and you plant against
an opponent to say like you know Drew
Brees and you gotta you know you this is
not ball control you got to be scoring
points and that doesn't happen so it
kind of puts you in a box and in a fire
where you know the PlayBook might not be
as expensive that week and wide open you
know we're gonna try to beat them you
know within the box within the the
hashes you know with the run game and
short passes and then all of a sudden
need long passes so I had some games
where it became different
early in my career too like my second
third year before we went into a game
with so many players that you know if
anything was to happen and you know we
got stymied and we can go to something
that you know can open up the playbook
and you know change the dynamic so yes
early in my career I didn't I see that
sort of in in in a couple games that
Lamaze played in this year where he was
just stuck in a box my face wasn't
opened up enough Michael Vick here and
the Rich Eisen show which offense could
you excel in the most right now in the
NFL today that you see if you could come
back as the you know fresh out of
Virginia Tech version of yourself on the
field yeah which often she said that's
the one that I could be the MVP and when
I superwoman
um I would say the offense that that
Lamar is running right now because this
it's not just his own rebase it's a part
of the offense but I think Greg Roman is
probably one of the best at it you know
he did a great job with Colin Kaepernick
he did a great job with a large cellar
and any time he has a mobile quarterback
they seem to do very well and I think he
understands the run game really well and
then passing off for the run game which
includes the RPO
which includes bowlers own reads I think
it just puts defenses in a bind and if
you have the talent to take advantage of
that for four quarters and you're gonna
really stand out so I think I will be an
amazing quarterback in his system well
it's funny you mentioned that because a
lot of people think the Ravens can't win
the Super Bowl with this offense even
though as you point out Roman was the OC
for Colin Kaepernick and they were they
were one red zone success away from
winning at all yeah yeah and it's almost
the same formula race don't want to give
away too much at a game plan because I
mean listen you know we talk about the
game and you give insight but that's
what we supposed to do but it's up to a
defense to stop what they're trying to
do but man I think I think they can they
can get as far as they as they want to
go obviously they have to open it up a
little more and come with new concepts
as the season goes on so it can't always
look the same
in a sense and it has to continue to
evolve and it got to be creative after G
Michael Vick Iran the Rich Eisen show a
couple more minutes left with you you
know you were out here for the AFC West
let's just quickly turn the NFC West
right here you got the Niners undefeated
the Seahawks at five and one Russell
playing out of his skull I think he's
the clubhouse leader for MVP does the
jail and Ramsey trade is it too late for
the Rams you think the Rams can win this
division again with Jalen now on the
fold how does this affect it knowing
that it's not too late and the one thing
it does just now what half of the feel
for all remaining ten opponents that you
had left throughout the season
Zana is one of the best corners in the
league and sometimes at this juncture
the season you got to make a move was a
change in order to you know fulfill some
spots they needed to be you know
corrective if that's what the team sees
needs to be done and you know it's gonna
be good for the Rams I mean not good for
other teams in the division but you know
Seattle you know and the 49ers are
already at the top of the division and
it's going to be a long hill it's gonna
be a long climb they'll have to go on a
winning streak and around this time of
the year teams need to start winning you
know three to four games in a row that's
how you make your playoff push you got
to get hot and the teams that get hot
right now are gonna win games well I and
it's obvious that the 49ers and the
Seattle Seahawks are already hot so the
Rams have to you know they got to strike
that match so Michael last one for you
here on before we send you off into that
day when when you look at the entire
landscape of the NFL and what we just
heard from the Commissioner 17 game
season how do you think that's gonna
land in front of the players
I think the players will accept it um
you know and it all depends on if they
cut out a couple preseason games I'm
thinking you know to even one the
players are there they'll compensate for
that you know I don't think there would
be a difficult decision um you know it's
just one bigger check that you get you
don't get paid for the preseason game so
you know combine it all into one game in
the game that count I think is our girl
for the NFL and uh I'm certain enjoy
you're rich because I love the game of
football and I love watching it every
Sunday so you know it makes for a longer
season
um I'm happy I didn't play 17 games when
I played well as a spectrum that's where
I was gonna go Michael I mean you know I
don't know you're feeling these days but
you used to take some hits you know one
extra game is III would think that even
any extra games might be a non-starter
for for the Players Association yeah it
might be tough but I think what guys
think about the money today generate the
money that's going to be made and the
money they put in their accounts and
save you know what's one more game you
know what's one more game of
entertainment you know fulfilling your
stats whatever motivates you within the
game of football you know with uh you
know one more opportunity but rich only
at the you know only at the expense
there you know this I wanted one or two
preseason games taken out you know and
then I saw this training camp and then I
guess you will to the season a lot
quicker so I think only only if that
happens then you know the 17 game season
make sense Michael thanks for the time I
enjoy having you on there and I look
forward to seeing you on on the grind I
hope you do a whole bunch of them
oh man I hope so too man I had so much
fun doing it it's gonna be awesome
so the excellent terrific I look forward
to that Michael Vick right here on the
Rich Eisen show check him out on on
Epic's on the NFL to grind him with
Phillip Rivers for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on the
live or download the Rich Eisen show app